Film Courage: Steve what is Serendipity?
Stephen L. Stern, Comic Book Author/President of
Storyboard Graphic Novels: What is serendipity?
Well one thing it is a world famous ice cream
parlor in New York City, are you familiar with it?
Film Courage: I’m not. Is it still open?
Steve: To my knowledge it is. It’s world
famous for amazing ice cream concoctions
but the to answer your question more specifically,
I think by Serendipity you mean wonderful
things happening kind of out of the blue?
Film Courage: Sure.
Steve: Yeah yeah without planning
the opposite of planning.
Film Courage: And do you believe in Serendipity?
Steve: Yeah I'd say my life is
pretty much serendipitous yes.
Film Courage: How do you open
yourself up to Serendipity?
Steve: Oh that's an interesting question sort
of an existential question I think what happens
is Serendipity either happens or it doesn't
happen to you I don't think it's like falling
in love you can try your best to make something
happen in your love life say but if it's going
to happen there's this ineffable thing called
chemistry which allows it to happen and I think
the same kind of operating principles relate to
Serendipity in your life sure I got a great gal
for you she's studying to do this and then you
meet the person and it's not there's nothing
there and then right the person who's totally
wrong for you and yeah it happens right do you
think an artist can hurt themselves in some sense
or their career by not believing in Serendipity
well I mean I can't speak for other people but
I believe that whatever you you believe you put
out into the universe okay sort of a karmic thing
so if if you're open to serendipitous good things
randomly happening to you in life they most likely
will happen so it's it's being like almost like
receptical for things or or a vessel somehow for
for interesting things to happen stopping to talk
to people on the street maybe you've been warned
don't speak to strangers but sometimes amazing
things can come from that yeah well actually this
is the Story of My Life basically the the best
some of the best things that ever happened to me
in my life came out totally serendipitously out of
the blue completely out of the blue do you have
any examples of some serendipitous instances in
your life I'll I'll give you a primary one
okay so I graduated from the University of
Miami Florida and then got a scholarship to law
school and I went to law school school for that
the first year I decided that law was not for me
so I tell my mother who was a single mom at the
time my dad had passed away earlier I said to my
mom I'm going to drop out of law school I'm not
going back for the second year okay and I'm going
to New York to do what I've always wanted to do
which was write comic books okay so my mother
being a Jewish mother and I being her only son
and her being a single mom my mother was not too
happy with that decision as you might imagine but
I was confirmed in this is what I was going to do
so my mother says to me well we live here in Miami
Beach and it's very warm you're going to go to New
York and it's very cold hold there right now you
don't have any warm clothes and I said Mom you're
you're right so I get this idea in my head I'm
going to go to Macy's and buy some warm clothes
now I had probably been in Macy's twice before
that in my life I don't know what impelled me to
go to Macy's but before I go there my mother also
says it's very expensive to live in in New York
City so and you don't have that much money saved
up from various little jobs and whatever so she
says to me how how are you going to afford living
in New York and I said I don't know Mom but I'm
going to do it so here comes the Serendipity and
when I tell this story to people they they're just
Gob smacked by it some at Macy's maybe the third
thir time in my life in the store and I'm at this
circular clothing display where you can turn the
rack and it comes around right so I'm looking at
the small amount of warm clothes I have there on
this circular display and I turn it to look at
some of the other stuff and suddenly I look up
and I see there's a woman on the other side of the
circular rack and I go oh I'm I'm very sorry you
were looking at clothes and I moved them away from
you okay so she laughed and we started talking and
I tell the woman I'm I'm buying these clothes we
get a little conversation we're buying these clo
I'm buying these clothes because I'm going to New
York to write comic books and she laughs right
and she says to me this she says so where are you
going to live in New York and I say I'm not really
sure and then she says to me me this she says I
happen to own a rent controlled apartment on East
79th Street at Second Avenue and next week I'm
going to Europe for a year would you like to suas
my apartment now you tell me wow what are the odds
a billion to one that that would have happened but
that is how Serendipity to the max Serendipity
squared got me to New York City and when you
went home to tell Mom what did she say oh first
she she didn't believe it she could not believe
it but then when it was confirmed to her by this
woman that this was indeed happening my mother
gave up in terms of trying to get me to go back to
law school cuz she just figured well I wanted this
and somehow the universe gave it to me so if that
isn't one of the most incredible serendipitous
stories I've ever heard it's fantastic I was just
curious what type of law were you practicing were
you sorry well I was just in the first year of law
school and you don't even know what you're gonna
practice yet okay you just got to get through that
first year which is always considered the toughest
year which I did do and it's usually considered if
you get through that first year the rest is like
a breeze so for me that decide not to go back was
not a happy to anybody but me a happy decision you
have many stories about serendipity one of which
is right there in your hands and I'm wondering if
you can hold up that beautiful cover for us yeah
gorgeous and this has become your life's work yeah
and that is a another instance of serendipity yeah
okay so you see the the book on camera okay I'll
put it down now all right so in the mid 1980s my
wife and I moved to the state of Maine where we
had a very good set of mutual friends and I was
the owner of an advertising agency in Princeton
New Jersey prior to moving to to Maine and then
when I sold my Ad Agency in Jersey and moved to
Maine I reestablished my a agency there in the
town of Auburn Maine and so my very good friend
who had a lot of connection in that area started
giving me names of his clients for his accounting
firm and said they could use some advertising
there was very there was no advertising agency
up there in the mid 80s until I got up there right
so here's what happens I go to see a new potential
client named Cody's oldfashioned ice cream now
this may sound like small town stuff in Maine
but Yankee Magazine which is like the Arbiter
of all things cool in New England called Cody's
ice cream quote unquote the best damn ice cream in
New England so they were serious ice cream company
right so I go to the office of Nancy Cody co-owner
with her husband Roland of Cody's oldfashioned ice
cream and I'm looking around and I see in her
office these fabulous pen and ink drawings put
up around the office and I look at them and I
say hey whose art is that and NY says that's
my son Dan and I'll tell you what Steve if you
use Dan as the artist on all of our advertising
I'll give you the account so not being stupid I
immediately said yes plus I Lov the artwork that
I saw okay so week later I go and I visit Dan
at his home and we get talking and I tell Dan
about how how I've been dabbling in comic books
my whole life and how much I love them and he
said said man I would really really really love
to work on a comic book with you in addition to
doing the advertising so he says you got any ideas
what could we work on now I have to go back I got
to do a little flashback couple of days before I
go to meet Nancy and then Dan I'm unpacking from
our move from Jersey to Maine and this suitcase
that I had a lot of stuff in falls on the floor
cracks open and one piece of paper flies out
it's a one-page synopsis of a story called Zen
now what what was the backstory of this synopsis
when I was living in New York City for about a
year and a half as I mentioned earlier I started
writing comic books and I mostly wrote comic book
stories for these black and white sort of like
horror magazines with titles like Nightmare and
psycho things like that witches witches tales
and what would happen is you would hand off a
synopsis to the publisher okay and then artists
would come in to the office in Midtown Manhattan
visit the publisher and look at the various story
ideas and if they liked an idea then you could
write the story and it would be published right
and that happened to me with a number of stories
but never with this story called Zen so before
I left New York the publisher gave me back that
one-page synopsis which came with me to Maine
which fell out of the cracked open box that I
presented to Dan and thus Zen was born once again
if that isn't Serendipity then I don't know what
is.